hey youtubers is Charlie so DC day is
not over
they dropped some new Justice League and
they were talking about a Superman TV
show eventually coming to the CW there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video I'll be
announcing winners at the end of the
video so be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
get a lot of questions about the
giveaways the winners are always
announced at the end of videos so what's
going on today is like a DC day they
drop that promo announced that all of
the DC TV shows were coming back
basically announced like the black flash
they announced so levar then while that
was all going on this justice league
stuff dropped and you can kind of see
that this is the bat-jet is basically
like a big jumbo jet that Bruce Wayne
and Wayne tech have repurposed is sort
of like a mobile fortress that they fly
around and so this is them climbing out
the back getting ready to kick some ass
the biggest thing that everyone's noting
here in addition to like the way they
show off their costumes which look like
way more detailed than we've seen in the
past is that there's no Superman so
presumably this is happening relatively
early in the film but after Aquaman has
joined the team because during the
trailer they showed off a comic on like
the test footage they were still trying
to get him he said he'll fight with us
[Music]
probably more or less he said no they
said no in Batman's like yeah he said no
so something is gonna have to happen in
the movie with Darkseid's minions to
change Aquaman's mind usually it's like
the threat on Atlantis like if something
threatens the Seas the people he cares
about those are the things that are
really at stake for him because he's not
friends with any of these people yet
eventually they'll become comrades and
he gives their life for them but in
justice league they're just not there
yet like they haven't got to that point
so the flash is like the only one in
addition to Wonder Woman who is like
totally down to help out in really just
based on what they've shown us the flash
is the only one who's super eager Wonder
Woman wants to help out but she's not
like jumping up and down to hang out
with Batman but just look at some of
these costumes so we've gotten like the
behind-the-scenes look so you've seen a
little bit of it without CG this looks
very close to what it's actually gonna
look like in the film now this is like a
picture that was copied a couple
different times so it doesn't look quite
as colorful as it will in the movie but
you do see Batman's new suit they've
already shown that off a little bit he
has the goggles but it's basically like
a slightly more armored version of his
cloth suit but a lot more mobile than
the tank suit that he wore when he was
fighting Superman so it's kind of that
Dark Knight joke where Lucius Fox is
like ah you want to be able to turn your
head while you're wearing the bat suit
so this is a suit built for fighting
parademons hardcore enough that it'll
defend him against a couple blows but
lightweight enough that he can move
around in tight confined spaces I really
did like the way the Batman moved around
during Batman vs Superman they did take
some liberties like he seems super
strong but it's a comic book movie so I
think most people understood that but
when they introduced him in that
underground lair he really does kind of
move around like a bat just like
clinging to the ceilings it was great
you've seen the Wonder Woman trailers so
you know how she moves you see her there
with the god-killer sword that's the
sword of Athena it's capable of piercing
doomsday as well as Superman's skin so
she as well as Aquaman are actually
going to be very important for fighting
Steppenwolf because he'll probably be
just as tough as doomsday obviously like
a slightly different type of fight than
them finding doomsday because he'll be
physically smaller but Aquaman very
important to that because his Trident is
also capable
piercing doomsday as well as Superman's
skin so anytime you have someone with a
weapon or with like a physical ability
like a metahuman ability like the flash
that's capable of harming someone that's
as strong as a dark side or his minions
or Superman they become the most
important person in that fight so I know
a lot of questions like how powerful is
this version of the flash the way
they're presenting him say like compared
to the TV show version of the flash
grant gustin's flash is that you have to
imagine TV flash moving at SuperSpeed at
all times and then briefly slowing down
just so that he can interact with other
people but for the most part he
experiences the world in that super fast
state which is why he has all these
monitors on even the Rick and Morty
monitor over there you can see it in the
background he's moving so fast that it
seems like he can take that all in at
the same time even though you know when
he's moving at SuperSpeed he's still
reading it just like a normal person
would read it or watching that episode
of TV so if you didn't see the videos I
did during the summer there was a big
set visit a bunch of people got to watch
them film a scene the flash really helps
anchor the tone of the film makes it
more humorous just more fun like oh my
god this is so amazing I can't believe
that we all get to team up the biggest
question is cyborg obviously they've
done a lot more CG work on this version
of the costume than in the test footage
we saw at Comic Con
I heard about you then thank you for
real that was really just preliminary
stuff this is actually much closer to
what it'll look like during the film
which is just nuts in Superman's costume
I don't think it's gonna change too much
it'll seem more colorful like the blues
and the Reds will stand out more but
that's really I think just in the way
that they edit the film just the way
they color time it they wanted to see
much more like brightest day than
blackest night like Batman V Superman
was meant to be this really dark serious
tone Justice League is still dark but
it's a lot more hopeful than Batman V
Superman I like all these but ranking
them from favorite to least favorite
I'll say Aquaman is my favorite right
now his armor looks so badass in the
Trident I can't wait to see him in
action with full CG then the bat suit
then Wonder Woman's costume then the
flash and cyborg just because I haven't
really seen what the cyborgs costume
does it's full CG meaning that it's
going to be moving around a lot lots of
moving parts but until we get that first
trailer we just won't know how that's
gonna work and I know everybody wants to
know when that first trailer is gonna
drop they were originally gonna drop it
sometime in December but now it sounds
like all the election stuff that's
happening scared them off and they're
gonna wait to the spring so if we hear
anything else about it I will totally
include it in future Justice League
videos so let me know whose costume is
your favorite from the Justice League so
far but what about the Superman TV show
that everyone was going crazy about it
was like a little bit of a tease at the
tcas so like I said you know they
dropped this flash season for arrow
season 6 DC TV promo and they talked a
little bit about the Superman property
so like hey you know Superman was
awesome this year on Supergirl
are you going to make a superman TV show
Greg Berlanti said that they're really
hopeful in the future that they can do
that but they're not actively developing
one right now so Tyler hoechlin is as
close we're gonna get to a Superman TV
show in the near term but eventually we
will see that Smallville reboot even
though I don't think that it'll
literally be a Smallville reboot it'll
be like some different type of Superman
show that we haven't seen before but in
the way that the Berlanti verse brings
back classic actors for the new TV shows
I do think there's a solid chance that
when we do get to that Superman TV show
they'll bring back Tom Welling in some
Merl just depending on how far in the
future that is like he might not quite
be old enough to play jor-el but they
could do a Jay Garrick John Wesley Shipp
type thing where he plays a version of
Superman from a different earth because
we do have the multiverse
so next couple of years no Superman TV
show just Superman on the Supergirl TV
show let me know in the comments though
when they do get to it what do you want
them to do for Superman do you want it
to be a metropolis do you want it to be
in Smallville do you want him to be part
of the Justice League I feel like we
want Justice League if all the shows are
still on TV we want TV Justice League
congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner alex gets toasty please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video so I'll just
remind everyone the next time I post a
DC video while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn all
about the flash season for the shows
that are coming back and you can click
here for the trailer for the next
episode of the flash thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys in the
next video